here we go ladies and gentlemen from the
daily mail stephen colbert's the late
show staff who were arrested for
unlawful entry to the capitol last month
will not be prosecuted doj says they
wouldn't have been able to get
convictions of those including triumph
the insult comic dog
now why is that is it because uh they're
in dc and dc likes these people is that
how it works i would assume so but let's
read see the nine members of the late
show staff arrested for unlawfully
entering the capital last month will not
be prosecuted the doj has ruled the
capitol police released a statement
monday night in an update on the
incident involving members associated
with stephen colbert's talk show
uh they say the u.s attorney's office
then confirmed they would not be moving
forward the case because they wouldn't
have been able to secure convictions
according to a statement obtained by
axios so let me just uh here we go they
say the united states capitol police
have been working with the u.s
attorney's office the district blah blah
blah the us uscp arrested nine people
for unlawful entry uh because members of
the group had been told several times
before they entered the congressional
buildings that they had to remain with
the staff escort inside the building and
they failed to do so the u.s capitol
police was just informed the u.s
attorney's office for the district of
columbia is declining to prosecute the
case we respect the decision the office
has made colbert dismissed the
comparison between the arrests and the
january 6 right as a non-surrection and
joked triumphed the insult comic dog
should be charged with first-degree
puppetry
no it's a point it's a point about a
double standard he should be arrested
for that joke seriously i mean the show
is just not funny it used to be did you
like it back like back in the day when
he was doing the just the o'reilly thing
and a lot of people didn't even know it
was satire i thought it was different
and funny and then it just slow
trump made comedy like comedians just
brains break essentially and uh yeah
it's political punditry if you watch the
beginning of the show it's like a
political monologue almost at least the
last one i watched once i had to turn it
off yeah no i didn't have to i chose to
there you go you're old man finito i had
enough stephen colbert and his fake
smile like he's one of those people look
at pictures of me that he's smiling even
when you know like he's not necessarily
happy today he's just a joker it's that
kind of smile where you're like oh
you're hurting inside yeah what's going
on there
so so mike sternovich tweeted this when
you have absolute power you don't even
need to pretend even as people face
trial for walking into a building with
open doors dc democrats free their own
regime propagandists that is one way to
put it yeah but i think it's true they
would not have been able to secure a
conviction because you bring triumph the
insult comic dog actor into a courtroom
with with uh jurors from dc and they're
gonna be like but they're the good guys
they're allowed to break the law right
also i mean first of all if he was in
court my god i hope they would let him
like actually act using the puppet would
be amazing but
for the jury a demonstration of your of
your show
okay here's the thing hey that would be
[ __ ] happy
houston houston august where i can
actually say that and not feel bad um i
i mean i remember
so my last day job i was 22 i worked at
borders books and music in columbus
circle where i
all pretty much almost got fired every
day i would hide under the desk and
drink cough syrup i was a very sad
boy but cnm was right there and the one
time i hung out with robert smeigle who
does triumph it was me robert smeigle
and tucker carlson
just wait what just kicking it like no
you're joking no i swear to god it was
before the second george bush uh
election tucker wasn't like
known as he's wearing a bow tie yeah he
was no he was wearing the bow tie and he
was just like ah bush is gonna win but
like he didn't seem thrilled about it
they were just hanging out they were
just like literally kicking it drinking
uh outside of of this borders and
it was one of those moments where i'm
like
this whole thing is fake this is weird
it's all it's all fake like nobody
actually there's no one on the right who
seriously thinks that
colbert and triumph the insult comic
dogs should be arrested and then
the majority of people on the left not
on twitter
either they were sort of fed
complete fear propaganda about january 6
or they're just kind of indifferent
about it you know what i mean i mean
the the polls show most people actually
don't care they don't care they're like
what i mean i will say it is different
in the sense that
colbert
funny or not is attempting comedy was
attempting satire just like if we tried
to do a bit on the white house steps or
whatever for for cass castle um whereas
january 6 was politically motivated
both our first r1a issues so your right
to satirize insult and mock is the same
as your right to march to the to to the
capitol in protest the thing is
so i so look the people who ride it in
smashed windows obviously you charge
that's what that's on camera they're
being violent they're destroying things
you know that that pisses me off they
were like there was like a book book
stand by a window that someone smashed
into it's like bro that's like an
artifact of this country one of the like
if not the great like the greatest
nation on this planet in terms of
expansion of civil rights and and the
hard-fought battles we've had and you're
like just besmirching this awesome stuff
but the people who entered the building
when the doors were opened
did nothing that yeah they walked up one
guy had a cop waving him in and he
showed that to the judge and the judge
said okay dismiss that's insane you
can't charge someone for that the fact
that there are people still sitting in
jail or that that old lady that old lady
was not look
correct me if i'm wrong but that 69 year
old cancer patient i'm pretty sure
wasn't smashing windows and fighting
with cops it could have been a russian
asset bro you don't know she was charged
with trespassing because people on the
other side of the building that didn't
see the riot walked up to open doors
there's a video of police opening the
door saying i don't agree with it but i
respect it and those people are like
yeah and they're being let in right but
the colbert people get let go
yo we got serious trouble in this
country if there's two-tier legal system
you should definitely let that old lady
go i didn't know about that she was
probably just looking for her grandkids
or something who knows i mean
regardless it's like she's 69 and she
has cancer dude give her two months
she's probably two months yeah it's it's
really obvious the message they're
sending you know
this is why so many people just side
with the left on everything
refuse to speak up
because they know which way the machine
churns they know which way the valve is
going and if you just blindly march in
lockstep
you get you get leeway you get you get
free access but if you're some you know
doofy maga guy who sees the cop open the
doors and smile and wave you in and take
a selfie with you they're going to put
you in solitary
yeah this is really troubling to me
because i see this as the politicization
of our justice system which should upset
everyone and i know the left isn't going
to think this is a big deal until it
comes for them because they never tend
to but the fact of the matter is that
this will affect everyone and anyone
who's looking past what thomas soul
calls the first stage like stage one is
gonna realize that this is gonna turn
around and bite them really hard
somewhere down the road i gotta read
thomas soul i yeah you do i used to say
this when i
uh when i
got in a bit of trouble for talking
about drone strikes on conan when i was
like hey if i know we like obama i know
he makes cool spotify playlists i know
his wife seems awesome and he plays
basketball and they high-five and
fist-bump and she has a garden but also
if he is droning weddings and children
even if you like it when obama does it
because obama doesn't like a cool guy
way yeah uh you
who was gonna be the next president and
everyone was like it's fine and then it
was donald trump and it's like that's
why people need principals instead of
parties if you have principles these are
the principles i stand for then it
doesn't matter who's in power and in
fact you should be more upset when it's
your team
going against your morals because they
represent you so man shouldn't you speak
up that's why when it's like i hear cops
speak up against you know bad cops yeah
man that's really important when you
hear liberals talk about how wolf
culture has gone crazy it's like yeah
it's like you know the people you get
mad at the most in your life are your
family and one it's most of our families
are insane but also it's because like we
love them they mean the most to us so
you're more emotionally invested i wish
people did that instead of just blindly
going on twitter and i used to do this
something controversial would happen and
i'd be like man i don't know about this
issue and then i'd see how sort of my
team lined up and i go all right well i
guess that's the tweet i guess i gotta
side with them or else i'm gonna get in
trouble that's the craziest thing when
the covington catholic thing happened do
you know about that the coming catholic
thing too so like you you're like being
thrust into politics and like
so there are these kids standing on the
on the steps of the lincoln memorial
minding their own business when some
dude gets in his face banging the drum
someone snipped that video from like it
was like a really long live stream or
something wasn't it and then they put up
this clip making it seem like the kid
got in the face of the native american
it was like mocking him or something
and so i was getting inundated with
people who were like moderate
libertarian right-wing being like dude
tim did you see this this is messed up
like it's making us look bad and then i
was like what is it and they were like
bro this kid got in his face and i was
like really i where's the video and like
it's right there i'm like that's just a
video of two people standing in front of
each other
but everyone just got in lockstep and
this is the problem with modern politics
but this is also why you will not be
criminally charged because not one of
these people is like i'm not going up
against the woke mob for this no you
like do you think the dc prosecutor is
like oh yeah i'll get reelected if i do
that sorry no no it's all political if
you get arrested like steve bannon right
now he just walked out of court recently
for the contempt charges
a dc jury
they don't care apparently i saw a
fraction of this one i just saw it and
there's a lot of preliminary work to be
done a juror apparently said i don't
care what he says i don't i won't
believe a word he says because of who he
affiliates with well that person should
be on a jury that's right
but this
look
when uh chauvin
was being was going to be tried in
minnesota
they tried to get a change of venue but
the judge said there is no venue in the
state where people don't know about this
case
my opinion then is case dismissed if you
can't have a fair trial you're done
right you could maybe ask for another
state to hold the trial where people
don't know but you can argue if
everybody is biased against you and you
can't have a fair trial you cannot be
tried you are free to go because it is
better that 10 guilty persons escaped
than one incent person suffer instead
they were just like yeah we'll have a
sham trial there's riots outside the
jurors are being brought in with armed
police officers carrying rifles and
everybody is terrified of the riots and
the jurors actually said they were
scared of the rights but uh seems fair
to me that's where we're gone
sherman got the book thrown at him and
then two weeks ago i think what they do
like five life sentences or something
stupid what it was i don't know
some ridiculous i mean to be fair
he's a murderer like that was not good
and also set back like this again is
what i was talking about right it's like
you have something that blatant it's not
a black lives matter verse blue lives
matter oh we're gonna get into our first
fight no i don't think i don't think you
watched any of the case i don't think
you uh
the video yeah i don't think you know
anything about it i just watched the
video there's multiple did you watch the
the full nine minute body camera footage
and did you listen to the police experts
no tim i'm trying to live a happy life i
just saw what twitter wanted me to see
and i saw the guy who killed and i was
like all right i'm done the show it when
you learned the drugs that uh what's
george floyd was on he was on five
different drugs i think
he was fetting all he was behind the
wheel of a car high on fentanyl
personally so he should have been
arrested immediately for that stuff meth
methamphetamines yet
marijuana why did you guys tell me that
before i wore my george floyd t-shirt on
the show tonight you need all types come
on man he asked to be put on the ground
floyd did but shelvin did murder him he
did kill him i mean and as far as an
illegal killing so that's considered a
murder i mean every uh here's what i'm
basing it on uh cause no i of course i
didn't know that stuff because i that
you probably had to dig to find that
stuff because it was so against the
mainstream i'm basing
what i'm talking about on the cops i've
talked to who were like
they actually had the continuum of force
shown in the trial and he said because
george floyd was on drugs not you know
like they don't they don't know exactly
what he was doing but he was belligerent
kicking in the chair and screaming at
that degree the state allow the police
are allowed to use tasers
chauvin i don't believe pulled him out
of the v i'm not sure if he pulled him
out of the vehicle he asked to be pulled
out he was in the back that was before
and then they pulled him out later on no
i don't know if sheldon was involved
when chauvin arrived he was kicking to
get out of the vehicle and the state
that was prosecuting chauvin said
yes he could have used a higher degree
of force but chose not to right then i
was like whoa you got reasonable doubt
on murder you have a cop who is who is
told by his training that he is allowed
to use a taser but said i'm going to do
less force that i'm actually allowed to
do
right there i'm like that's it he had no
intent to kill him well but he did less
force improperly and this is why there's
a picture no no the training manual of
the police doing that exact maneuver
yeah no no no but what i'm saying is
improperly in the sense that and this is
from the cops i've talked to as well
they are trained horrifically one they
don't train enough to a lot of their
training is antiquated especially when
it comes to hand-to-hand combat i was
listening to jocko talk about the
response of the uvaldi shooting and he
made a great point that i will quote now
everywhere i go whereas cops should
spend
20 percent of their time training period
training in firearms training in
tactical situations training in jiu
jitsu if you
i mean one a taser probably wouldn't
have killed him whereas that improper
choke would have any blue belt you
trained jiu jitsu for a year two years
you know how to put someone who is on
drugs the reason jiu jitsu is great is
because if someone's on if he's all high
on pcp and i break someone's arm and
stuff he may not feel it all right hold
on hold on so for one
i think there was a probably justifiable
manslaughter charge in the duration of
the the the uh the restraint yes right
but that's about it the the issue is
do we tell this one officer who was
instructed to do everything he did that
he's going to pay the price for the
broken system to appease a mob or do we
change the system instead of actually
changing anything all they did was lock
this guy and the other cops up and then
tell all the activists mission
accomplished and the activists went away
well this is the problem with so many
issues is we just try to duct tape
solutions so people move on to the next
thing they're angry about and we don't
actually change the system this happens
with all the systems that are broken
where it's like i think
between that between the school
shootings we absolutely need to be
focusing on like getting cops better
training and it doesn't seem like that
means defunding them it means getting
them better training and letting them
train more instead of just you know sit
around
i i concur i agree
well to wrap it all back up with the
with the the point of the segment though
just to make the point no that's enough
everyone agree with me
i was gonna say regardless of
um
like
what people believe about the case it's
really dangerous how many people pass a
judgment on it without watching the
trial yeah and without getting all the
evidence politics 101
we sit here on the show we pull up the
clips we watched written house we had
how many seven witnesses to the written
house case on this show yeah journalists
people involved people who are like i
can only say a little bit because i've
been subpoenaed
and then from these interviews we were
like it's very clear kyle rittenhouse
was innocent
but the did the media do any of that
it's remarkable that you've got people
who are like you know tim cast isn't
journalism what we do isn't journalism
and it's like well for one this show is
political commentary on journalism
but when we're sitting here with you
watching these videos showing you the
sources explaining why we think this
source is good that's like
a million times better journalism than
say the new york times lying about you
know ukraine or something and trump well
and also we can ask questions that's why
i love being on this show where it's
like when you asked me if i saw that
video i was like nope
like this is what i saw and now that is
going to of course and it should
uh inform me whereas if i knew something
you guys didn't
you guys would do the same thing right
but look
i i think one of the strongest divisions
between left and right of this country
is the left doesn't know anything about
the news and the right does and that's
really it it's exemplified a million to
one when i point out ground.news bias
fact check twitter blind spotter load up
ben shapiro like the most prominent
conservative orthodox jew and you'll
find him balanced between left and right
wing news you pull up the entire nbc
news team and it's all 100 left wing
that was me remember yeah so so that
this is the issue with this country
is that
these people like washington post cnn
whoever else who smeared the covenant
catholic kids
yeah because they don't read they don't
watch they did zero investigation and
you know what i did i watched the
two-hour live stream someone was like
what happened i was like well i better
watch this two-hour live show on
facebook to see what it's all about and
i was like
so the black hebrew israelites were
there and the kids were heckling them
because they're racist anti-semites and
then this native american guy got up in
their faces and someone snipped that and
accused them i was like okay so i made a
video about it saying why is everybody
doing this even conservatives were like
they didn't read anything i was amazed
by that then you got aoc she fabricated
her january 6th story completely
fabricated it and i'm just like dude
look
there is a uh the exception on the right
that prominent figures will put out fake
news it's the exception it happens i'll
call them out it is the rule on the left
almost everything they say is always
just misinformed malformed nonsense well
the bottom line is if you truly believe
in your convictions if you truly believe
in your side if you truly believe in
what you are voting for then lying
exaggerating
not letting the other side not even
addressing the other side
it's going to completely contradict what
you're trying to do it's just going to
turn people against you there's just two
cultures in this country and
we're seeing the emergence of there's an
article today i was reading about the
emergence of parallel economies
and uh i'll i'll do this shout out too
we'll go we'll uh
several years ago i said the dangerous
thing about censorship with what's
happening on twitter facebook youtube is
that it will lead to what's called a
parallel economy we've seen this
pre-world war one
when people stop trading with each other
it creates distinct economic blocks that
can arm and develop resources
and then sustain a fight with each other
if there is one economic system a
sustained fight is not possible because
one group that gets excised from it
struggles to maintain any kind of
resources this is the goal of sanctions
we're going to cut you out of the global
financial payment system and then you
can't wage war against us although
that's failing because i would argue you
know joe biden but now we're actually
seeing it and the funny thing is about
the emergence of the parallel economy
we're a part of it
we are actively supporting the company
called parallel economy which we use
sign up at timcast.com and support
parallel economy but they literally call
themselves parallel economy that's art
imitates life and there will be a
multitude of parallel economies this is
not not the last but i don't i i think
it might start uh you look you've got
getter parlor truth social that's a sort
of fracturing but eventually
the quote unquote right will will will
have its singular space which may be
truth social it will have its track its
version of silicon valley which is
forming in florida with rumble and
parallel economy i believe parallel
economies in florida i'm not entirely
sure but you're gonna have the emergence
of a tech sector on the east coast to
compete against the west coast tech
sector and they're gonna have two
different kinds of rules and then you
look at truth social on the left like
we're not going there and the right's
going to be like twitter stupid i got
banned i don't want to be there anyway
and then you're going to have two
communication networks two financial
service networks you are going to have
states completely odds with each other
like you already do and then
well
and then you know i think the worst
conflict can come from having a
unipolar economy because
people are more like when you look at
revolution all these horrible bloody
revolutions pretty much
maybe not all of them but i'm saying the
revolts against monarchs not all of them
but a lot of the horrific stuff we've
seen in society is a revolt against a
monarch i guess you could say that two
parallel economies might come to blows
as well but i find like slave uprisings
are more dangerous and insidious because
people will blow up their own land
to get out and
i mean of course an enemy will blow up
your land as well
man maybe they're equally as dangerous
thanks for checking out this clip from
timcast irl come hang out live monday
through friday at 8 pm eastern time
super chat we'll even answer some of
your questions if you want to check out
the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time